MÁTÉ BEZDEK: My dissertation is
on fundamental investigations
that looks at interconverting
ammonia with its elements,
nitrogen and hydrogen.
PAUL CHIRIK: It
was clear that when
he applied to Princeton
in graduate school,
he was somebody special.
So he came to us from
the University of Calgary
really highly recommended.
You could tell just
from his application,
he was a deep thinker
and a real scholar.
MÁTÉ BEZDEK: Anybody who goes
into science is a curious
person, and I think is driven
by this desire to find out more
about the natural world.
So that was science broadly,
but I think chemistry,
specifically, because
to me, chemistry
was this really nice balance
between a theoretical subject,
one that is
intellectually satisfying,
but at the same time,
it has a pretty large
practical component.
The idea would be to take
ammonia, which is NH3,
and take it to its elements,
nitrogen and hydrogen.
And the reason you
really want to do this
is because of the hydrogen
you can generate this way.
And hydrogen is is the
ultimate clean-burning fuel,
and so, what we
were able to show
is that we were able to make a
so-called non-classical ammonia
complex with molybdenum.
And so the unique
thing that happens here
is that when you add ammonia
to this molybdenum complex,
instead of just
sticking, we were
able to demonstrate that
the NH bond in ammonia
is no longer strong.
It becomes extremely weak.
That then enables a hydrogen
evolution to take place.
Perhaps, there is nothing
more fundamental in chemistry
than the concept
of a chemical bond.
And to me, if the fact
that we were still able
to make a contribution
to this concept in 2016,
when we first did
this research, is
what made it so
exciting and so unique.